and I was telling him I was like yeah I
actually was trying to buy one and I got
ripped off and he goes and he looked at
me and goes you got to always check if
the thing actually turns on
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
careful boy that's right uh where today
we have Anthony Joe Nick Bart Steve
Green and myself
let's talk about um don't let this
trigger your rage but let's talk about a
time where you genuinely got ripped off
oh dude whether it was from a scam
whether you got Short Change whether a
deliverable didn't have I got one I
bought a [__] I was trying to buy is
it during the pandemic I was trying to
buy a PS4 of OfferUp this is my first
time buying something
and it was like 200 bucks or something I
was a good price so I met this dude at a
[__] I met this dude at a CVS and he
sent me a video of like yeah see it
works and I was like all right cool
grabbed it and then I went home and I
was like can't wait to play my [__]
PlayStation plugged in doesn't turn on
uh at all and I was like
what the [__] and I was like what a
[__] idiot I'm like I was so mad
that's not even the worst part this is
the worst part I went to go buy another
one
and um
I bought another one and I go I pulled
her up again offer up again I pull up
and it's this little Indian kid
he's right there and I'm like what's up
man he's like I'm here to buy that he's
like you're for the PlayStation on my
yep he's like come on in
and I was like talk to him and he's like
he's actually kind of funny and I was
telling him I was like yeah I actually
was trying to buy one and I got ripped
off and he goes
and he looked at me and goes you got to
always check if the thing actually turns
on
I was like yeah totally yeah totally man
and then I walked out and I was like
damn this even this [__] 15 year old
knows how to buy a PlayStation better
than a [__] 30 year old man so
[__] I was like I felt like such a
[__] idiot I was like and you get
home you plug it in it
he goes come on in I'll show you that it
turns on okay and that's what he said to
me and I was like oh and I was telling
him I was like I got ripped off and he
goes yeah you always gotta [__] check
dodo bird what are you [__] [__] and
I was like yeah I totally did I am I am
immoral let me let the [__] page here's
your money thank you
I price gouged myself oh that's cool I
willingly bought something expensive
during covet which was weights in a
barbell oh those things that set was
like I think 200 something brand new and
I got it for like 800 bucks whoa brand
new it was 200 something yeah holy [__]
and I didn't even get the 45 plates with
it it's just because it was inflated in
in price at the time yeah I got
everything else but the 45 plates and I
was like well it's a set it's got the
weights then I went over and then that
guy I bought it that's the one you
helped me sold and then he was like
you got any more friends and stuff that
want gym equipment and I'm like you can
get more of this [__] yeah during covet
I don't know what it was but people want
fitness equipment so much that people
that weren't even in Fitness for hitting
me up like yo if I order a palette full
of gym equipment would you help me sell
it what do you mean you don't know what
it was gyms were closed here's all of
the inquiries for those weights people
got that into gym equipment because like
remember those the adjustable dumbbells
those were some they're like you give me
like 300 bucks they were selling for
like twelve hundred dollars of them
that's why people kept asking why there
weren't any Ford fives yeah
yeah and you're never getting
this for 10 years I'm never getting
Animal Crossing for your and you're
never getting the the Nintendo switch
branded Animal Crossing that was like
you might as well lick a guy's butthole
and suck his dick for [__] 20 years
because you're never gonna pay for it
did you guys get into animal
s scam
I want to say six months or so ago I was
buying a van
and um it was just regular Facebook in
Hawaii yeah in Hawaii and then
um
it was just a like a Honda Odyssey and
it was for a good price it was like I
want to say like five six grand so I was
like oh [__] cool you know and then call
them up and then they call me back and
then we play phone tag and then she was
like oh um we're about to move out so my
husband's leaving we're gonna leave the
island
um so we just have it parked on the
street here you know where this place is
I'm like I know exactly where it's at
I'll go meet you up so we go these two
girls pull up in like a Kia and then she
goes oh that's the van so we go up I
inspect the van and this thing is like
kind of [__] up mechanically like the
radiator I know something like I opened
it up and the radiators like leaking
like there's some major [__] that needs
to be fixed so I drive it around the
block but the first thing that kind of
makes me feel odd is like I turn on the
AC because you got to turn on the AC and
everything right and then she goes oh
can you turn that off um I get allergies
and I'm like oh okay so I turn it off
that is weird so I turned out I opened
up all the windows right you step
outside now I'll keep you I'll stay
inside let's go play so I was like oh
allergies right and then so she stays in
the van with me we do a quick little
Loop and I'm like all right yeah it
works but man the alignment's off
something's off and I'm like damn this
is really not worth it because I'm gonna
have to do a lot of work and I'm like
but if you give me a good ass deal I get
it you know and I'll and then I was just
like how about like 3K because this Pro
this thing is probably gonna cost me
like 10K to fix up or whatever like it's
too much right it does maybe like I
could flip it or whatever I'm just
giving her out it's giving her [__]
allergies yeah you have the windows down
which doesn't give her allergies but the
air conditioner gets right it's a lot of
work I wasn't really thinking I wasn't
really thinking because all I was
thinking about in my head was the
mechanical issues and I'm like
is it gonna be worth it to fix this
thing that's what I was thinking in my
head so
um I we get in her car right and I'm in
the back seat
and then I'm um we agree on a deal I
think it was like 4K or something like
that I'm counting the money out
and then first thing I notice is when
I'm in her car the AC is on full blast
and I'm like you just told me to turn
off the AC I'm thinking that right and
then I go hey um
let's write up a little like contract
because I need to I need to do this all
the time anyway right so then
um I go I uh name bill of sale bill of
sale that's pretty common right so I
told her to write it
when I got it
there were like information missing and
like the VIN and all that and I'm like
what the [__] and I'm like
show me the pink slip and then so the
pink slip shows up and I'm like so you
said this is your husband's and she goes
yeah and I'm like oh okay cool
all I need is the ID so I can put my ID
and his ID together and we take a
picture of it and it has to match the
pink slip and she goes
so I'm like this doesn't sound right
right and then she's all like yeah um
and I'm all like did you pay like all
the red like current registration
because I just noticed that the tags
off in date so I'm like what if this
[__] has all these like back taxes and
all these things and once they sell it
to me I'm like [__] right back
registration yeah she goes no no she
goes I got everything we could take this
to the DMV whatever and I'm like okay I
don't know if I want to pay 4K for this
[__] no more this seems like a big ass
headache right and I'm looking at all
this stuff and I'm like yeah you know
what
get your um husband's ID and you can
tell him to take a picture even if he's
not here just send it to your phone and
then send it to me and then we'll make a
deal and I'm like if you can't find
anybody's ID your name doesn't match I
don't know who this pink slip belongs to
yeah so I'm like no deal and she goes
are you sure I'll give it to you for a
better price and I'm like
oh nah bad answer right so I get out
and I thought the weirdest thing was
like as soon as I got in the car she
[__] peeled out and she boned out and
I was like you know what this van is
still in front of me so I got the uh
license plate and I looked it up to see
if there was any like if it was stolen
or whatever I have a cop buddy out there
I told him to go check it if it's stolen
or anything and it had the [__] most
like a thousand bucks for this thing
this builds a ticket that was unpaid it
was all this [__] on it and I was like
dude and on top of that another fishy
thing is these girls were clearly like
Eastern European or something and they
said they were local
they don't speak pigeon they don't yeah
like die hard villains dude and I was
like we're I was like aloha
we are from Idaho
come on come on brother
I was like I said
and then I was like you guys grew up
here they're like yeah and I'm like cool
where are you from who hasn't we are
from McDonald's
oh they're like they're like yeah we're
from here I'm like where locals Place
Zippy's
locals Place yeah they said locals
please
yeah this episode is brought to you by
dragons can you believe we've had seven
months without an NFL game crazy right
well good thing that's over and NFL is
here and drafting Sportsbook an official
sports betting partner of the NFL is
giving you a can't miss offer for week
one this week new customers can get two
hundred dollars in bonus bets instantly
when you bet just five bucks on any NFL
game DraftKings is hooking everyone up
with game day greatness all customers
can take advantage of two new offers
every single game day this September so
check the app to see what you get
download now and use the code off the
Record to sign up new customers can take
home 200 dollars and bonus bets
instantly just for betting five bucks
that's called off the Record only on
draftking Sportsbook and official sports
betting partner of the NFL the crown is
yours definitely problem call 1-800
calendar or visit
www.1800.net in your call
8778-h-o-p-e-n-y or text h-o-p-e-n-y
467-369 and Connecticut health is
available for problem gambling call
888-789777 or visit ccpg.org please play
responsibly on behalf of Boot Hill
Casino and Resort KS 21 plus age varies
by jurisdiction void in Ontario
ccdkng.co football for eligibility terms
and responsible gaming resources bonus
bets expire seven days after issuance
eligibility and deposit restrictions
apply
and um so during that same time there's
been a lot of gypsies in Hawaii
there's been a string of gypsies in
Hawaii rolling up to people and they're
doing jewelry scams yeah these things
are different yeah they put it on people
it's actually they do that to happen
yeah they do it to old people they're
selling fake gold
um or they put it on people and say
please I need gas money can you give me
cash I'll give you this cheap jewelry
whatever right and then like there's
been a string of cons that were
happening and I think those girls were
uh trying to sell off a [__] up car
that they got yeah so it's like
I probably should have got it for like
500 bucks to be honest I could have
dealt with all that but she wasn't
willing to go under three yeah
I think they still had a price yeah Joe
[__] Joe man yeah they gave you that
offer though they said they would go for
a cheaper price and you're like nah dude
I'm not gonna take care they wouldn't go
under three really yeah so I was like
[__] that it's not worth it greedy
bastards yeah you have to make the I was
just worried it was stolen so I had my
buddy run the plates and it wasn't so I
was like well I would have taken it for
500 bucks but damn
there was a there was a point where I
bought a um I bought an iPhone where
um I wanted to upgrade to the newest one
because mine had got a cracked screen so
I was like oh let me see on um on what
was let go at the time and if there was
like a freaking cheap phone for the next
one and I got one and then I realized uh
that I could just replace mine through
insurance I didn't know I had it so I
was like oh [__] now I got this phone
that I don't need I bought it from like
some Asian guy right here in Alhambra
um he just seemed like a normal dude and
then when I when I tried to sell the
phone because I didn't need it anymore I
met up with this like nice Armenian
father and son like it was like his
kid's first phone and he was like super
excited but they wanted to do the uh
purchase legitly where you go to the
actual like T-Mobile store and you do it
there place the SIM cards yeah exactly
yeah and we did it there and then when
they tried to activate the phone that I
bought it came up as stole oh so I
looked like the [__] thing no yeah oh
damn and it was the worst feeling
yeah I did yeah I just felt like running
dude wait is it because your phone that
you bought was stolen you didn't know I
never activated it I bought it from a
guy thinking I was gonna use it but then
I got insurance to cover my phone anyway
so I never activated so when that
happened were they like uh we can't have
this what would they like now you give
it to me for Better Price they didn't
even say they just looked at me and they
were just like like speechless and
they're just like I'm sorry I bought it
for someone I never I just said what I
like the truth yeah but who [__] who the
[__] would say but then again why would
you like go down
like why would you go
it's a stolen phone I mean I guess they
just think I'm a stupid criminal yeah
you know what I mean that was the worst
feeling man I was living in Koreatown
and my roommate was moving out my
girlfriend uh and I had broken up and my
roommate who's like we moved to LA
together with my girlfriend so it was
like it was really the ultimate breakup
right so I was like okay [__] I gotta
find a new roommate or whatever I'm
gonna keep my spot so then um I put out
[__] on Craigslist and everywhere and
all that all the different places I get
a response from some chick and she's
like yeah hi I'm looking for a place to
live this will be great
um I want to move all my furniture
though I live in like Europe and I want
to move all my furniture here so I'm
gonna give you a check
and I need you to like I'm gonna give
you a check you go put it in the bank
and then I need you to give me a
cashier's check
oh yes sir a deposit scam and it's gonna
bounce on you it's gonna bounce on me
but but she'll get my money via Western
Union which is what she demanded you I
need Western Union so bad it has to
happen quick
and I was like
I don't know what the [__] any of this
means but I'm down I was 23 and I was
like sure I'm down and then I was just I
just when I was walking to the bank I
had the worst feeling about it I was
like this just feels awful but I don't
know what the scam is yet
because I wasn't I wasn't sophisticated
about anything having to do with money
yet at all so you didn't know checks
could bounce no I knew checks could
bounce but I didn't know that like
she gave me a check for like five G's so
it felt legit it felt legit and she had
sent me like pictures and like it just
seemed like a real human being because
it probably was a real scammer on the
other end
but then as soon as I
um went got to the bank
I remember handing the clerk the check
and be like hey deposit this
and then I remember being like okay I'll
do the Western Union thing after work
because it's like on the other side of
town
and then I remember like
getting back to my job and being like
okay I'm sorry I have to leave and I
went right back to the bank and I said
that's a fraudulent check cancel it
and then I
well I went to Craigslist and I searched
for dick pics and then I I found a
picture of a I found a picture of a
guy's dick he like had a gut and he had
like a micropenis and then
dude that's the front of the perfect
place to find dick pics that is the best
place for a wall amateur Craigslist yeah
and then I sent back I was like I sent
this girl right
um I was like Hey I just did the Western
Union thing just want to let you know
what you're looking forward to
[Laughter]
and then Bank of America confirmed to me
like within three business days that it
was a fake checking yeah dude Good Thing
Man good thing that would have been a
really [__] sad thing yeah especially
back when there's not enough money to go
around like I credit my mother because
she always said trust your gut and I
just had the most Eerie feeling about it
yeah yeah the last time I almost got
scammed was I think this could be maybe
2003 2004
2005 maybe damn you went nearly 20 years
unscathed huh you [__] smart guys and
then uh it was because uh so I was super
into cars I'm still into cars but I've
always like fixing up cars and I had a
buddy that was really deep into the car
scene
and so he like he knew all the hookups
like he knew the whole so like the
system of how to like get your car
sponsored like fully Decked Out is and
he learned it probably three cars in
once you start building all the
relationships what you do now is you
pitch to all this is before the internet
obviously but you pitch to all the car
the k n air filter look at the
Flowmaster yeah Toyo Tires whatever you
pitch to all the companies I already
have a three-page spread in the next
Import Tuner
they're super down because it costs like
10 G's per page to get uh if they were
to buy ads but if they just give you
free product they're getting three pages
for like a thousand or two thousand
dollars better than an ad yeah so my
friend he he knew this whole system and
he had like a whole thing of uh networks
already so I had this like lower truck
that I was trying to get wheels for and
he's like I'll hit up my buddy he can
get you like a crazy deal and these
wheels I think
they're probably retail for like four
grand at that time and I could get them
for
I think like 2500 or something like that
so I met up with his friend his friend
owns a uh his family owns a restaurant a
Vietnamese restaurant in Rosemead and so
I cut him a check and then I thought I
asked him if am I going to get a receipt
or whatever and he was like oh no don't
worry like these this is has to be one
of those things that's like under like
not on the books because it's not
authorized whatever
and I told my friend that who's really
so I'm really tight with my friend and
he told me that other guy's really tight
with him so I'm like okay if that's if
there's two levels of tightness like No
One's Gonna screw each other because
we're all really really close
and I told my friend I'm like is that
true is that how it works and he goes ah
sometimes it could be like that like
sometimes like you know people like that
are negotiating they'll get a couple of
things off the back end but they can't
really have it in the book so they'll
just the main company will claim it as
losses or whatever
so maybe he's hooking you up that way I
mean okay cool these are custom wheels
made specifically for this car that
won't fit on any other car so it takes
like eight weeks to make because they
have to like literally Forge the rim
yeah I remember eight weeks I'm already
buying it I remember eight weeks
pass by
I hit him up oh yeah you give him like
the runaround then another like month
goes by then he starts ghosting me I
don't know what the [__] happening I
hit up my friend my friend to hit him up
I'm like I don't know what's going on am
I like annoying him like he has like
half of my money which is the deposit he
he ends up telling me that guy's not
responding him too and it drags on for
maybe like
I would say four months and then when
you're like early college a couple Grand
is a [__] ton you know and I'm like holy
[__] and then so like I'm like dude what
the [__] do I do I also promised myself
I'm gonna live a good life because my
urge is to go to the parents restaurant
and just destroy the whole thing and I'm
like but I told myself after the Marine
Corps I'm not gonna do anything crazy
like that anymore and I'm like should I
like find out where he lives and beat
the [__] out of him I don't know and I'm
like just like have like this this
internal yeah and you're like how long
does it take to forge a wheel
exactly am I getting scammed question
yeah and I'm like what the and I talked
to my friend and now my friend it has
lost has lost lost complete connection
with that guy and I've lost complete
connection and
um
I remember feeling pretty desperate but
not knowing what to do and then all of a
sudden I think like six to ten months in
I get a phone call from a random shop in
like West Covina and like hey we have
your wheels and I was like
what the [__] like I almost killed you
for these and then so I went to the I
went to that place and then I was like
the other guy the guy's name was Jimmy I
went to the place I was like so is Jimmy
here like whatever and he's like no just
uh we don't really talk to him anymore
he just he just randomly told us and he
says your wheels are here so I ended up
getting my wheels there's legit it ended
up falling through I don't know what
happened if I had to like
like eight weeks and you never talk to
them ever again ever and were the wheels
as good as he had said yeah because it's
from a legit company so he was probably
doing some shady [__] got caught or
something so imagine like Jimmy like
it's not bulk but like it's like a
company like Volk yeah and then so it's
like a legit company and then you just
know someone that's like really deep
into it so you just know you're not like
it just it was such a weird interaction
I don't know if it was like Jimmy's own
personal life got the best of him so he
was like oh [__] I'm short on cash let
me just take this money real quick and
do something and maybe he never actually
put in the order for my wheel and then
he was thinking something was going to
come back
some other thing but then finally I was
able to get those Wheels
put on and I was just like that was so
crazy I bought these helium miners
called Panther miners during the oh yeah
they they never came
right so like I bought these miners for
helium
like which is a crypto that's right yeah
and I I spent like I don't know probably
600 a piece on them so 1200 bucks right
and I remember like I was like okay I
have a plan like during the bear Market
I'm Gonna Be Mine helium no problem so I
already had two miners just that I had
bought already
and actually I had three I got three
miners I bought already and I was gonna
have five for the for the Bear right so
then um yeah these two Panther miners I
got from this place in China
I was like
where the [__] are the miners and
they're like oh no we sent them it's all
good here's a tracking number and [__]
and I'm waiting waiting
three months goes by I'm like where the
[__] are the reminders and like they're
in Indianapolis and I'm like that's
ironic but okay and then I um they said
that there was a customs issue with them
and I was like you guys are [__] me
around dude you guys are full of [__]
and [__] me around I would have believed
it yeah I'm an idiot dude well I right
but they said there were I had to submit
something to customs like about my
personal whatever the [__] to release
them to release them yeah from custody
or whatever and then they said I had
just missed the window so they were
being shipped back to [__] China what
the f and then yeah and then I was like
just give me my money back [__] you guys
dude and by this point like everything
was like dead in crypto and I was like
just give me my money back I could spin
it up anyway and then like they're like
oh sir you're you know we still haven't
received the miners yet we're waiting
three weeks ago I get a knock on the
door at like 10 in the morning and
there's a there's a FedEx guy and it's
like back to the [__] future too it's
like we had a bet down at the yard it's
like it's raining we had a bent out of
the office
uh wow this guy reached out we were told
to bring these things to a guy named
Steve at this place in Las Vegas and
I'll be dead they lost the [__] bet
and they gave me this box that looked
like it like went like through hell
yeah yeah they got my [__] miners
dude the reason why I didn't buy it is
because there were so many people
complaining that they never got it but
some people got it but they were talking
about how it was like so difficult
that's why I never bought it
how I feel about that we'll see I'm not
like not stoked about it's not cardano I
don't hate Salon I hate card I don't
know I feel good about it what would you
have done it was cardano rage but I
would never have bought it so yeah yeah
but yeah I got it but yeah the guy
couldn't believe it he was like we've
been we've been having bets about this
thing I'll be damned I guess I lost
it's like compared to the Future too
I got something for you yeah so yeah
dude these are the best stories that
I've got
[Music]
thank you